POPOWEWER.R.
[C[CHEHEERERS S ANAND D APAPPLP
----HEHE
U.U.S.S.A.A. D DEVEVELELOPOPMEM
HUHUGHGHESES
JOJOHNHN: : WOWOW.W. S SWEWEDED.
CLCLARARKEKE..
[C[CHEHEERERINING]G]
KIKINGNGS,S, D DYLYLANAN G GUEU.
NANATITIONONALAL T TEAEAMM D DEM
THTHE E CHCHICICAGAGOO S STETEEW
ROROSESENN.. C COSOSSASA.. B BIY
NANATITIONONALAL T TEAEAM M DEDT
PRPROGOGRARAM M CHCHAZAZ M MHLH.
JOJOHNHN: : THTHATAT'S'S A A
SESELELECTCT F FROROMM B BOUOUR.
W WYAYATTTT J JOHOHNSNSTOTON.N.
JOJOHNHN:: A ANONOTHTHERER M MIN
WOWOLVLVERERININESES..
A A TITIGHGHTKTKNINITT F FAMAMIM
S
JOJOHNHN:: H HALALIFIFAXAX, , WO
SESELELECTCT, , FRFROMOM S SWEWU
SSSSONON.. S SELELECECTT A A T .